[Music]
we were the smallest town for a while
do we still wish we were I don't know to
be a population of one in the population
of two and you're both in the same
County in the same state I think that's
pretty wonderful
what is the population of mono i
population 1 me the population of gross
Nebraska is 1 2 1 2
we don't have enough people it's nothing
against the town's nothing against the
people running the businesses we simply
have run out of people out in this this
area all we have in town is the bank
vault that remains from the gross state
bank then we have a community hall and
then our house and a trailer house
across the street
we had a high school here there was
Church until pull maybe the mid sixties
we have the same paperwork and
everything to fill out that Omaha and
New York City and every other city has
we don't have an election for mayor I
just let him keep that job
[Music]
the young folks or any that go from here
to the city they can adjust pretty well
and make a good life there but you take
somebody that's born and raised in the
city and they usually just can't hack it
out in this area never gets lonely
living in a town of dude there's always
somebody passing through values are
different you don't have everything at
your fingertips so you just learn to
sitting and converse more I'm not here
because I have to be I can close up and
leave here anytime I want to go wherever
I wanted I'm here because I want to be
here
welcome to auction school will you give
me 20 will you give me 20
what five thousand what five on a womman
vibe to it sold by our number one dude
oh here we go rock'n'roll the Missouri
auction school was founded in 1905 it's
the oldest and largest auction school in
the world
it trains auctioneers in every aspect of
the auction profession and is known as
the Harvard of auctioneering introduce
the item ask for 10 drop to 5 I'll give
you the five and then go to six so we
start every morning at auction school
with group drills
just like an athlete would warm up we
need to warm up very good ok give
yourself a hand at auction school the
most important aspect is that auction
chant now for you three bid not 25 25
its soul the very foundation of the
auction profession I'm a $20 billion now
thirty nine thirty will you give me
thirty I'm a Tony down a bit okay let's
try that the auction chant is two
numbers the money that you have bid and
the money that you're asking for I have
one dollar bid now - now - will you give
me - to another bid now three now three
when the imagery I'm going to doesn't
give me 20 where you give me 20 feel
that said that said good job and as they
sell more and more those filler words
will slur so it'll move a little bit
faster send me a little bit or not one
on one I'm better not to these
everything we gives everything Dominic
things everything's and
17:42 I'm a 41 year we even imported to
142 thanks they're on a boat 108 and
polar 100 on a polar so old 375 and
that's what creates that nice smooth
rhythm chan rubber baby buggy bumper
basic rhythm okay learning the auction
chant in a classroom setting is
important but you're not really an
auctioneer until you get to go to a real
auction and sell real items to Realtors
your way so if the student auction you
never know what's gonna come up for sale
and so you got to be ready for anything
first items lost 75 you got a stack of
three turtle got an old tablecloth
jumper cables very useful looks like you
know another stack of turtles lot number
six 63 is a meat cleaver so one of the
most fascinating aspects of the process
is the transformation that the students
make throughout the program so often
when they first come to the school
they're hesitant they aren't sure what
they're doing a lot of them are
frightened even once they get up and
they sell and they realize yes I can do
this I can really do this you could hear
it in their voice I'm an auction there's
three things that are most important to
chefs first is flavor second has flavor
and third is flavor flavor fools
[Music]
built on the Fertile former lakebottom
soil of northern Ohio the chef's garden
is a 300 acre family farm that grows
specialty produce for some of the
world's best restaurants the chef's
garden is a small family farm that has
the good fortune of working directly
with some of the greatest chefs in the
world in many cases we're working with
plant growers that are breeding to be
able to create new plants not genetic
modification but genetic selection the
farm grows produce of all shapes and
sizes
like miniature carrots these white
strawberries in almost a hundred
varieties of microgreens but the Jones
family wasn't always the chef's garden
my parents have had some very successful
years in 1983 they had a very
devastating hailstorm and ultimately the
farm collapsed we were dealt a new deck
of cards and found opportunity within a
disaster we met a European influence
chef iris Balin to grow me varieties for
flavor grow me varieties without
chemical I want a zucchini bloom thought
this lady was absolutely crazy little do
we know she knew a heck of a lot more
about it than we did and that really
opened our eyes to another whole world
out there we hooked up with some really
great chefs early on folks like Danielle
Beaulieu and jean-georges Vongerichten
and Alain Ducasse and Michel Rashard and
then Thomas Keller and Charlie Trotter
and in ritz-carlton chefs and for
seasoned chefs and they've allowed us in
existence in agriculture
we're indebted to those chefs that have
given us the privilege and the path to
be able to follow our dream of farming
so it's that symbiotic relationship of
chef and farmer working together for the
greater good and here we are 35 years
later still working to get better to the
best of our ability right now in this
place I think we're doing the right
thing and I think that trumps every
other reason for whatever you do in this
life
[Music]
[Music]
the town of regen is dying I said if
someone doesn't do something this
community will be a dead community I
have a paved road from interstate to
region now what do I do to bring people
down 30 miles
[Music]
then it dawned to me nobody's gonna
drive 30 miles for normal sculptures but
they might drive for the world's largest
I started the Enchanted Highway in 1989
I've been at it for 28 years and I takes
me roughly about four to five years to
do one sculpture the first year local
ranchers taught me how to weld I put in
eight hours a day to get one sculpture
done so I use bold oil well tanks I cut
them open and I flatten it out and
that's 90 percent of my metal it's a
passion project right now it started
with that world's largest tin family the
man has 45 feet tall the woman is 43
feet and the boy is 23 feet geese in
flight has over 300 lengths of oil well
pipe on over 15 miles a weld on it and
is in the Guinness Book of Records the
world's largest scrap metal sculpture
that's something I will continue on till
I'm six feet under and then I hope it
continues on after that I want people to
see that this guy who didn't know how to
weld didn't have an art class if he can
create something like this I can do most
anything
[Music]
hidden 150 feet below Kansas City in a
270 million year old limestone deposit
more than 1600 people work in the
world's largest business labyrinth
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]